j'ai eu de belles grandes surprises
j'ai une très grande déception aussi
professeur ali thq gabriel cadieux
leblanc a testé et analysé 15 rap
multifonctions c'est pas forcément les
plus dispendieuses qui offrent le
meilleur rendement sont les plus
tranchantes à quatre cinq ou six faces
style boîtier ou repliable les prix
varient de droit à 55 dollars pour
tester leur efficacité
notre experte a utilisé plusieurs
aliments de textures différentes
je me suis assurée d'avoir la même
taille d'aliments et puis de réaliser
d'une rapallo la même pression
et puis le même nombre de mouvements
pour au final calculer le rendement
comment vous avez reculé sans grand
volume moi j'ai pesé donc au grand
mangerez et aussi j'ai regardé au niveau
qualitatif
parce que dans le rap et à l'autre ont
une texture une épaisseur qui est
différente
parlons d'abord de stabilité les râpes à
cinq ou six faces sont beaucoup plus
stable il ya aucun ballan donc
automatiquement sans beaucoup
d'insécurité pour travailler certaines
rap à quatre côtés comme la cuisine bio
sont également stables par contre on ne
peut en dire autant des modèles
repliable comme celui ci de hope so
aucune stabilité y parle dangereux elle
est peu fou rire à n'importe quel moment
même si j'ai beau bien la tenir
fermement elle bouge parce que c'est
quand même redonné une c30 résidence aux
petites bêtes là celle-ci 36
lorsqu'on va ont vu que ce soit solide
antidérapant et confortable plusieurs
remplissent très bien ce mandat la plus
intéressante étant la cuisine bros pour
ce qui est du design de la poignée celle
de cette micro plane laisse perplexe ça
facilite pas le travail
on n'est pas à l'aise non plus tenir une
poignée mais sa surface pour trancher
est vraiment efficace parce que la lame
est bien positionné contrairement à
d'autres comme l'instant frites
étant donné que la dernière ouverture
ici est trop près de la base donc du
plan de travail lorsqu'on tranche par
exemple un concombre mais
malheureusement ça bloque
ce qui fait qu'on n'a pas un mouvement
fluide qui on est incapable d'avoir des
tranches une forme alors pour des
tranches uniforme la rigueur d'eau et la
cuisine pro performent bien
les tranchées été réfléchi à la bonne
hauteur même si on a un bon gros
concombre une belle grosse carotte
on arrive à faire des tranches complète
uniforme le mouvement est fluide qualité
mandoline sérieusement le j'ai une
estimation avec ses côtés trancher leur
gabriel a aussi utilisé le concombre
pour tester les côtés des râpes à trous
moyens presque tous les modèles font de
beaux filaments sauf la paderne j'ai
fait c'est le concombre qui en fait le
seul rendu que j'avais c'était de l'eau
la carotte a fait de tout aussi bons
résultats sur presque toute l'europe
sauf la paderne eau et la micro plane
avec l'âme amovible et à ce moment là
une pression forte puis on doit bien
tenir l'aliment entre les mains et est
tranché
la plupart des rampes produisent des est
moyen sans uniformité
contrairement à la lagostina qui fait un
beau geste de fin avec la micro plane
élite aucun effort pour rester
mais attention elles prélèvent aussi
beaucoup de la membrane blanche qu'on
appelle
les east qui est amer les fromages aux
textures molle ou semi molle sont
bienvenues sur toutes les races et les
durs de durs comme le parmesan
ce rapt sans effort sauf avec la roma 2
1 les troupes sont trop espacées
donc à mon aîné vient qui ont rappelé
dans le beurre au rap de l'air quatre
rapts nous donne de beaux résultats avec
le gingembre
mais la palme revient à cuisine pro à
l'intérieur on y retrouve également une
rare agen jambre et on conserve tous les
jus de gingembre donc aucune perte
une belle poudre de muscade vous aurez
avec 4 rames la plus performante étant à
nouveau la cuisine pro et que dire du
fameux côté dont on ne se sert jamais le
rendement est hyper décevant donc que ce
soit le petit roues perforées août où
s'agglomèrent chez ricardo on a réglé le
problème
ils ont eu l'idée brillante d'enlever le
côté qui généralement retient toutes les
particules pour offrir une ouverture un
petit peu plus grosses banques l'ont
moins on a quatre faces fonctionner
fonctionnel 3 rap honteux réceptacle
avec couvercle pour conserver l'aliment
râpé en conclusion certaines ont été
polyvalente à tous niveaux
mais plusieurs dérape tester une deux
trois faces non utilisable si on nous
vend quatre côtés seront alors vous
voulez payer moins de 15 $ et vous rap
et surtout du fromage la bonne vieille
robe classique et latines kitchen mais
si vous voulez investir un peu plus dans
la qualité numéro 3 en 1 ricardo la
deuxième position est la plus chère
on retrouve la micro plane donc encore
là
les lames sont très bien aiguisé on est
stable on a une bonne poignée
antidérapante signaleurs ça et vous
aurez devinez qui est la grande gagnante
de notre portée s'est
la cuisine pro sans aucun doute le rendu
en rien à voir avec toutes les autres
apps et la qualité du produit fini elle
réalise des zestes d'agrumes un rap et
de parmesan hyper fin hyper aérien il
n'y a aucun côté inutile tout les lames
sont hyper efficace c'est un super
achats
[Musique]